- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is think about how a person's
environment or experiences
affects their political perspective,
their political attitude.
So one way to think about it
is how is your socialization,
your political socialization?
How does that drive your
political attitudes?
And I encourage you pause this video,
think about your own political leanings
whether you lean to the left
or you lean to the right,
where did that come from?
Was it just you in a vacuum
thinking about things
or were you influenced by your family,
your friends, your
school, maybe the media,
maybe something that you're part of,
maybe a club or church,
mosque, synagogue or temple
and this is actually an area of study
for political scientists
and as you can imagine,
some of the things that I just mentioned
are significant factors
that people have studied
in terms of what develops
people's political attitudes?
If you come from a family
of staunch Democrats,
you're more likely to be a Democrat
or at least lean to the left.
If the environment of your school
or what you're exposed to in school
leans one way or another, you are likely,
more likely to lean in that direction.
If your friends go one
direction or another,
that could be a very powerful influence.
Obviously, what you're
exposed to in the media
and out of all of these,
the one that's maybe the most studied
is the notion of family and
to appreciate this idea,
let's look at this
diagram right over here.
So I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can make sense of this
before we do that together.
Alright, it says Percentage
Intergenerational Resemblance
in Partisan Orientation
and this date is from 1992.
So it shows three different scenarios,
one scenario where we are looking at folks
where both parents are Democrats,
another scenario where
we're looking at folks
where both parents are Republicans
and then another scenario
where there's no consistent
partisanship among parents
so either they are split
or maybe they are independent
and actually, if we look at
this third scenario first,
you see that it's a pretty
symmetrical distribution.
Green shows, of people whose parents
showed no partisan preference,
17% are pure independent,
about 18% lean towards the Democrats,
16% lean to the Republican.
That's about the same.
14% are weak Democrats.
14% are weak Republicans.
10% are strong Democrats.
10% are strong Republicans.
So it's a pretty balanced
distribution here
but then if you look at the scenario
where both parents are Democrats,
you see that of those
folks, only, what is this?
This is eight plus six is 14 plus seven.
Only 21% are Republicans.
And if you go the other way
where both parents are Republicans,
you have only 18% of those
folks become Democrats.
So this is just interesting
food for thought.
A lot of us really like to
believe, including myself,
that hey, I've come to
all of these conclusions
based on completely impartial thoughts
about how the world should be
but we are influenced by our environment
and especially from our family
and frankly, even the folks
who go in a different direction
than their families,
that might have been
because of their family.
Maybe they decide that hey,
that always frustrated
me one way or the other
so I'm gonna go the other way
or I'm gonna rebel a little bit
and I'm gonna go the other way
because I am a free thinker
but even in that situation,
you are being influenced
by your environment.